when it comes to animal crossing
consistency is the key to success with
that in mind we put together a list of
11 things you should do every day an
animal crossing new horizons so without
further ado let's dig in
hit all the rocks as strange as this one
sounds it's important to do everyday
hitting rocks will get you clay stone
iron Nuggets gold nuggets and of course
money in order to get the most resources
out of any given rock you need to hit it
multiple times in quick succession this
sounds easy but every time you hit a
rock you'll get knocked back slightly in
order to prevent this we recommend
digging some holes behind your character
with a shovel before you start smacking
it if done correctly every square
adjacent to the rock should be occupied
by either money or crafting materials
dig up fossils every day for fossils
will randomly spawn in your island equip
your shovel and look for cracks in the
ground once you've dug up for head to
the museum and assess the fossils
I recommend donating them to blathers
but if you're in a pinch you can sell
them for a decent price to the new
clangs check the nuke stop machine
inside resident services you will find
an ATM you want to check this machine
every day for a few reasons
first you can order from a rotating
selection of items including one cake a
slider song per day trust me they're
worth it second everyday you check the
nuke stop machine you will get some
miles and you'll get more for every
consecutive day you check in it does cap
out at three hundred after seven days
though so keep that in mind
talk to all your villagers you should be
chatting with your villagers anyway but
if you needed a more concrete reason to
do so you will get nook miles for saying
hello to all your villagers each day
there's also a good chance they will
give you something so it's a win-win we
recommend visiting villagers while
they're in their homes too since they'll
give you a DIY recipe if they're at the
crafting bench check the store
unfortunately you won't have an actual
store right off the bat but Timmy will
sell unique items every day at the
resident services tent so make sure to
speak to him when you get the chance
once the store is built Timmy and Tommy
will tell you about hot items basically
every day Timmy and Tommy will give you
double the selling price for a specific
item if the hot item is something you
can craft easily it might be worth your
time to craft a few and sell to the new
clangs for some extra bells check the
beach quite a few things can wash up on
your Shores each day you'll find
seashells throughout the day that you
can sell or using some DIY recipes you
might also find a message in the bottle
and since every bottle comes with a DIY
recipe it's in your best interest to
comb the beach every day occasionally
though more than just shells or bottles
will wash up if you spot Gulliver on the
shore keep talking to him until he wakes
up once he's up he'll ask you to find
his communicator if you manage to find
all five pieces he will mail you a gift
the next day check for visitors speaking
of Gulliver he's not the only visitor
that may show up on your Island
unannounced there are a handful of
special visitors like Celeste wisp Mable
Sahara and others who might show up on
any given day I don't want to spoil what
they do but you should definitely keep a
lookout for them glowing spots as you're
exploring the island you may come across
a glowing spot in the ground digging on
these spots will net you 1,000 bells but
more importantly it will leave a glowing
hole behind if you bike you can bury a
sack of money and in a few days it will
sprout into a money tree be careful
though if it's anything like older games
they aren't always guaranteed to bloom
we also don't recommend burying any more
than 30,000 bells
pick and sell fruit if you're looking
for some easy money pick and sell your
fruit the fruit native to your island
will sell for 100 bells coconuts will
sell for 250 and anything else for 500
if you come across fruit from another
Island we recommend planting it instead
of selling it right away so you can get
your own non native fruit trees hit
trees you will need a lot of wood for
crafting and your island can only
produce a finite amount each day with a
flimsy or stone axe hit your trees each
day this should net you a good amount of
softwood hardwood and regular wood
without cutting down the whole tree
while you're at it you might as well
shake trees too occasionally they'll
drop furniture or money or if you're
unlucky a wasp's nest however they do
sell for 2500 bells apiece so you might
want to get your net ready visit
unexplored islands technically you can
visit unexplored islands as much as you
want so long as you have the miles to
purchase tickets however we recommend
going at least once a day because some
of these islands can have some awesome
rewards for example we found an island
infested with tarantulas and one covered
with money rocks and that's it for me if
you want to know what we thought of
animal crossing new horizons be sure to
check out our review and progress and if
you're just beginning be sure to check
out our day 1 guide thank you so much
for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]